Is that my mouth to you this way? Nancy
Hart. Did she speak to you like this?
About positivity and about
my mom reinforced knowledge.
My mom reinforced you don't start things
and not finish them. You don't quit.
There is nothing that comes out of
quitting besides knowing that you didn't
finish. We finish everything.
You start it, finish it.
If you're going to do it,
do it to try and be the best,
not be better than other people.
Be the best for you.
If you're in school
and you go on to class,
I'm not asking you to get straight A's.
I'm asking you to get the best
grade that you can possibly get.
Give me 100% all the time
and I'm a happy mother.
When you have fast me, I'm on Yas mom.
I want to do this. I want
to. I want to play baseball.
Well then you're going to play mom.
I don't like that no more than why'd
you start the season cause I thought I
wanted to do it. Then you can
finish the season. You don't quit.
There's other people that
invested time and energy into you.
You don't just quit on people, but I
don't want to do it. Finish the season.
I want to swim. Then you're gonna finish
women. It didn't matter what I did,
I was never allowed to quit. So now
on anything I do, when I pick it up,
a Sam gonna start it. I got to
finish it. It all don't work.
It all linked the best. Mm. It
all ain't knocked out the park.
But I walk away saying,
I finished it. I did it.
I did it right now I've been boxing or
saw you working on with Rico Verhoeven.
I'm fucking, um, first of
all, very strong kicker.
He's your man. Huge man.
Okay. He's a fucking beat.
He's a good guy too, man. Good
guy. But I started the jeans.
I started it and I said,
why am I doing this?
I'm not going to be a
professional fighter. I'm not
trying to be amateur fighter.
I'm doing it to get in shape. All right?
Then I start getting shaped and I said,
Yo,
so much that I don't know about the sport.
I at least want to make sure that I'm
paying homage to the people that do this
for a living. By really understanding
and learning it. You know what,
I'm gonna get real trainer. I'm gonna get
some real people to show me everything.
So when it's all said and done and I'm
looked back after my training, I can go,
I gave it 100% and look at how good I got.
Look at what I'm a product of.
I spar, I go get in the, yeah,
just to feel it so I can say I did it.
You know who else far as Brian Cowen is
this, are you serious? No, that's me.
That's me. Come on. That's me, dude.
That's me is getting it to look at this.
Who is teaching him? His name
is bigs. He's in Atlanta.
That's me learning how to turtle
shell within punches. But you know,
he's a former golden glove guy. Really
good to you are in a cup and everything.
What I was this bar in session when I'm
Mike real tired. Damn Yada, got in touch.
I got my ass whipped in
every couple of times. Um,
I go with the guy worried about
that at all getting, cause I'm not,
I don't go crazy.
We head gear and I'm at it,
but I'm not in here with guys
that are trying to hurt. Yes,
I'm that I knew you was touching you
guys that have no concept of reality or
control. Like they're, they're
just helping me understand.
Here's why you have to keep your hand up.
That is a problem with celebrities
trying to spar. Like if you try to like,
you know, that's why I'm Mickey work
started getting all that facial surgery.
Are you serious? And you
sparring with James Toney. Jeez.
When I should just not a
smart move. Right. Criteria.
That's just, it's James. Tony.
He's a mean man. It's just, you can't
like I don't, I don't go in that space.
Have you ever seen James Tony Talk Shit?
Well he spars then some of the most
entertaining thing you'll ever find on
youtube. He's just, he just won't shut the
fuck up all the time. Beating your ass.
He's talking shit, bitch.
That's how Fitch, which got
Bitch, oh this ain't shit.
That's, that's hurtful. That's him. He's
one of the best defensive fighters ever.
So he's really difficult to hit.
He's got that shall go on,
stand right in front of
you and you can't hit them.
Most frustrating thing in the world.
Yeah. I had a guy who's got a Mikey,
I'm sparring with Mikey.
Mikey hit me with three punches.
I thought,
I thought Mikey literally
had like six arms.
This is true story.
I said,
I don't know what just happened but I
thought I had my hands up and no matter
where I put them he just tapped me.
He lets me feel it but not to
where I'm like getting knocked out.
But I understand now movement,
I understand pivots,
I understand shoulder
protection and that's my goal.
My goal is just to understand
cause I can't do anything halfway.
Kevin trying to fight
somebody. Nope. Nope.
I just want to say that I did it and I
learned and I can move and I looked apart
cause I put time into it.
Well as you learn it too,
and as you watch it and
you start to get trained,
then you start to look at a guy like a
Terrence Crawford or Loma Chenko and you
go, oh, now I appreciate what
you're doing. Because before
you'd see like, Oh yeah,
he beat that guy up. Oh yeah,
he knocked that guy out.
But then you see like how he ducks under
the left and fires back with the right.
You know what I'm saying? Oh Jesus.
This is precision. It's insane.
The respect that I have,
people that do that or the day
to day is through the roof.
The people that fight in the most
amazing shape and the universe.
Yeah, you're in the most
amazing shape ever to move,
get hit for three to five minutes around,
come back, do it, come back to it,
and these fights go on and on and on.
I take my hat off to you.
You get three rounds out of me.
I'm breathing out my butt.
I don't know where the air is coming from.
I'm searching for it.
It's a crazy way to make a living to me.
Yes,
I got it out in your brain
like thank God I don't,
I didn't have to go down that route
and you know, to those that do,
just make sure you just put your yet
body first. Like you said, it's a,
it's hurtful when you see the
damage that it can cause. Yeah.
We were talking about that earlier,
like seeing guys as they
start to deteriorate and it's
hard because nobody wants
to tell them that either everybody wants
to tell them that got one more good
fight them and let's uh, maybe at the
end of the year then we'll decide.
But right now we're going to
train hard and it's tough.
It's hard to because there's no options.
They don't,
once you've established yourself as a
professional fighter and you don't have an
exit strategy, you don't want
to do, you know now at least,
thankfully because of the Internet guys
are getting podcasts and they started
doing commentary shows that talking
about fighting and it's the positive.
She just sit there and
just found the positive.
The positive within the Internet there
is positive. Oh French. You just don't,
you just don't hear it celebrated as much.
We'll do dinner.
It's very positive for me. I mean, this
is this show we do on the Internet.
I mean all that.
Not just podcasts,
but youtube videos and also information.
I know more because of the Internet
than I ever would have without it.
There's not a, not a doubt in my
mind that though a more educated,
more aware person. I want
you to say Internet. Yeah.
The things that you're able to find
and search and I mean, like you said,
you're able to self educate at a,
at a very high level.
These are the goods we're talking about,
the goods.
So when you talk about positive
Kevin, hi, have you been,
I always liked that it's this, it's the
things that I look at that are so easy.